Thank You Cindy give team and
congratulations on making history 2015
my name is Brian moragne a proud
resident of lower house and I'm pleased
to serve as your class treasurer it is
now my great pleasure to introduce the
first student orator
of it this afternoon mini-movies joined
literature women gender and sexuality
studies quantitative by her critically
acclaimed and virally shared columns on
the Harvard Crimson or perhaps is from
Manifesta the social justice magazine
that she co-founded whatever it is
there's no denying Rowena KATUSA snack
for salient relatable and ever relevant
social commentary that has sparked
campus-wide conversations about the
issues affecting our community in fact
her senior thesis on the relationship
between LGBTQ activism and with
Bollywood film industry in India one of
the Yujin our comments price and shall
be returned into India after graduation
to expand on the research with a
Fulbright fellowship Thank You Raina for
always asking those hard questions and
of course been an awesome block mate and
so 2015 herewith I am out and so can you
is my dear friend renowned for Tola wine
critic and your 2015 Harvard female
orator ruin Gattuso
to the members of the Harvard College
class of 2015 with whom I have made out
hello
to the parents of the members of the
Harvard College class of 2015 with whom
I have made out your daughter is a
lesbian
do my mother I am now going to change
the subject I'm sure you read the title
of this speech and you thought this girl
has a gay agenda I do my agenda is so
gay
it co-hosted Ellen but the particular
gay agenda I slid in on a rainbow to
deliver to you today it's not just mine
and it's not just for gay people this
gay agenda is for all of us and it can
be summed up in two words come out when
was the last time you came out about
something I don't just mean sexuality
maybe you told someone you had a crush
on them maybe you opened up about a
hardship you have faced maybe you asked
for help when you really needed it these
are all different kinds of coming out
these are all moments when you could
have pretended that you were
invulnerable but you chose to be open
about the things that have kept you back
the things that have kept you down the
things you are afraid of when we are out
about these things in our work in our
relationships we allow ourselves to be
the brilliant unruly people we are and
we give each other permission to come
out - we are about to graduate from
Harvard University we are about to
graduate from one of the most esteemed
and wealthiest institutions in the world
and we are about to become bosses I mean
this colloquially I'm a boss you're a
boss Natalie Portman is a boss but I
mean this literally - a lot of us are
about to become very powerful people and
that's great because here at Harvard we
have all the skills required of affect
leadership decisiveness empathy
determination except one when it comes
to vulnerability we are a second rate as
Yale and that makes sense it is hard to
be out about the things that have kept
us back when everyone around us is
soaring many of us have been told that
we are the wrong race or the wrong
gender or from the wrong income bracket
or with the wrong abilities or with the
wrong passions to be truly great so we
hide but if we are going to use the
power we feel every time we tell someone
where we go to school to make the world
a better place we need to come out I
came out to my dad in May 2012 on the
same day Barack Obama came out in favor
of gay marriage everyone was talking
about gay people gay people and their
tasteful wedding decor gay people and
the downfall of America I was like who
me straight my father and I were
watching the news box said Barack Obama
is a birth certificate lists homosexual
my father said Reina I am so proud of
you for finishing your first year at
Harvard I said daddy I'm bisexual he
cried and then he hugged me and he
continued supporting me as I proceeded
to not only be out about my sexuality
but to write about it bi-weekly as a
columnist in the pages of the Harvard
Crimson
daddy even though I'm graduating I will
continue to write about sex on the
Internet
coming out allowed me to be more honest
with my family it empowered me also to
pursue the creative career that I love
and when I started opening up about my
vulnerabilities in the pages of the
Harvard Crimson something incredible
happened you all started talking back
you met me with stories of your own
struggles your own fears your courage
amazed me and your friendship taught me
that none of us not one of us is ever
truly alone what will you come out about
maybe you will speak up when something
makes you uncomfortable at your job and
you will begin a task force to address
diversity in your workplace maybe you
will ask for help when you hit a
roadblock on a project and you will
begin the collaboration that will make
your career maybe you will open up with
a crush about your complicated family
history and they will also have a
complicated family history and you will
make a complicated family of your own I
hope we have the courage to do it
because when we're out not only do we
think better work better love better
when we're out we allow the radical
breathtaking originality of our
personhood to shine through and we
validate the dignity of everyone members
of the Harvard College class of 2015 we
may not have made out but we are making
something the novels and the families
the governments and the economies of a
different better more just more
equitable future come out come out with
your entire weird wonderful being come
out for yourself come out for your
classmates come out for that nerdy kid
whose life you are about to transform we
need you desperately
the class of 2015 let's go make a more
fabulous world